Pamela Anderson was seemingly destined
for fame the Canadian model turned
actress was the first baby born on
Canada's 100 year anniversary as a
nation Pamela made her first film
appearance while still in high school in
the erotic Thriller Crimes of Passion by
October 89 she was on the cover of
Playboy magazine she moved to LA to
pursue modeling and started booking
acting gigs the following year
Anderson's Lisa became a recurring
character on Home Improvement which led
to her Casting as CJ Parker in Baywatch
a show that made her a household name
Anderson attempted to make the leap to
movie star in the mid 90s but the campy
comic book adaptation barbed wire failed
miserably when she spoke to interview
magazine in 2016 Anderson blamed Studio
intervention it wasn't supposed to turn
out like it did they changed the script
six million times